[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
mit diesem rezept möchte ich auch mein
kanal der ramadan saison einläuten und
zwar gibt es heute ein ofen rezept eine
passierte eine pastete ist auch muss ich
sagen so ähnlich wie barrick denn ich
mache dir passiert jetzt mit einem
hefeteig da kommt eine richtig schöne
väter schafskäse füllung rein und das
ganze kann man sehr gut vorbereiten ist
kalt aber auch warm das heißt da könnt
ihr wirklich auch wenn ihr fastet zum
beispiel morgens oder mittags irgendwann
das essen zubereiten unter machen abends
dann einfach nur kurz backen oder eben
nochmal erwärmen und auch für den
nächsten tag kann man da passte
wunderbar vorbereiten ich werde auch
gleich einfach zwei kleine pasteten zu
bereiten so dass man eine heute essen
kann und eine morgen die andere auch
einfrieren kann also eine pastete ist
etwas ganz ganz tolles und da kommt dann
einfach noch ein gemischter salat dazu
und fertig ist das leckere abendessen
es ist wirklich hervorragend das ganze
besteht wie gesagt aus einem hefeteig
ich sage euch mal kurz die zutaten dafür
verwende ich 30 gramm frische hefe einen
halben teelöffel zucker 200 gramm warmes
wasser 500 gramm mehl da könnt ihr
weizen oder dinkel verwenden einen
teelöffel salz etwas olivenöl 1 1 und 1
eigelb für den hefeteig gebe ich jetzt
einfach die zutaten in die rührschüssel
ich fange an mit hefe zucker und wasser
und dann kann man das ganze nämlich kurz
berühren
wir kommen jetzt die restlichen zutaten
einfach dazu je nach milchsorte kann
sein dass er vielleicht ein zwei
esslöffel mehr wasser braucht ich nehme
dafür gerne dass 405 weizen mit oder das
630 dinkelmehl ihr könnt aber auch wenn
ihr das ganze noch ein bisschen gesünder
haben wollt auch gern so ein bisschen
vollkornmehl mit rein geben das ist auch
ok ich muss nur persönlich sagen ich mag
vollkornmehl bei manchen dingen nicht so
gerne bei anderen dingen ist es okay von
daher gebe ich hier die zutaten einfach
rein kann den teig etwa zehn minuten
kneten und formen anschließend anfang zu
einer schönen rolle und lacina abgedeckt
von der stunde ruhen und während der
teig dann nämlich aufgeht kann ich schon
mal die väter füllung machen also diese
spinat führung
[Musik]
für die füllung nämlich zwei zwiebeln
eine knoblauchzehe oder ihr könnt auch
einfach einen knoblauch olivenöl
verwenden denn das öl brauch ich auch
dann jeweils 50 gramm pinienkerne und
kürbiskerne ein kilo spieler art das ist
eine ganze menge
100 gramm getrocknete tomaten 400 gramm
feta käse oder hüttenkäse salz pfeffer
und muskatnuss nehmt ihr euch am besten
zuerst die zwiebel und knoblauchzehe und
stellte und aktiv ein wie gesagt ich
werde jetzt gleich mit olivenöl anbraten
und da darf sich jetzt die knoblauchzehe
weg denn ich nehme einfach dass
knoblauch olivenöl dann kann ich mir das
schälen und fein hacken nämlich sparen
unternehmt ihr euch am besten gleich
einen richtig großen bräter denn der
spinat isst sieht immer extrem viel aus
bei spinat aber der vergleich total in
sich zusammen aber um schneller arbeiten
zu können nämlich einfach einen großen
topf von großen bräter dann geht es auch
alles schön auf einmal
[Musik]
da unten den wurzeln teil lasse ich
immer schön dran denn dann kann ich die
zwiebel besser schneiden
also im großen bräter schalte ich
einfach die große fläche ein
dann das öl gut schütteln
wegen dem knoblauch anteil
und einfach schön erhitzen
könnte hier nämlich die zwiebel
halbieren die wurzel hier hält alles
zusammen
jetzt auf die schnittfläche
einsteigen
und dann würde
[Musik]
ich dachte mir nach dem jetzt so viele
menschen da waren die keine zwiebeln
schneiden konnten und stellen konnten
darf ich mir erkläre ich mal wieder wie
man so eine zwiebel stellt und richtig
schneidet mal guckt am ende bleibt dann
wirklich so nur noch dass da übrig dass
diese wurzel vorne und dann hat man sich
schön und sicher geschnitten ohne sich
in die finger zu schneiden und dann
klappt das nicht wunderbar sonst kommen
die hier in den bräter
auf jedes halt echt viel viel schneller
mit seinem riesen bretter
sozusagen das macht es immer so ein
bisschen
geruch sparend immer schön deckel drauf
34 minuten anbraten und dann kann ich
schon mal den spinat ich habe zu ihren
schönen feinen spinat falls ihr den
größeren spieler habt auf jeden fall
auch ein bisschen schneiden aber ich
hatte nicht auch einfach so ein bisschen
grob schon mal
und früher die zwiebeln dann immer
wieder durch das die halt nicht an bord
sondern schön glasig antraten
[Musik]
sechseinhalb stunden später ich möchte
hat so ein bisschen wie
aschenputtel mit den linsen das wird um
wird um wird einfach nicht fertig mit
dem killerspiel
[Musik]
dann fange ich schon mal an anzubraten
also am besten gibt einfach
so viele spieler wie möglich rein den
deckel wieder drauf und dann fällt er
immer innerhalb von wenigen sekunden
eigentlich schon zusammen
und dann koche ich den einfach so ein
bisschen mit und trat ihn mit wie sehr
schön eingefallen ist du bist ja auch so
ziemlich viel wasser verloren hat damit
das ganze eben keine suppe wird sondern
später auch
schön festwirt und aromatisch
endspurt
ich wollte halt eigentlich zuerst ihnen
gerne beraten bist du hast habe ich
wieder vergessen
naja
macht nichts
da braucht man dann schneide ich so
lange noch die getrockneten tomaten kein
und zwar nehme ich da am liebsten
entweder soft tomaten weil sie schön
weich sind oder tomaten die getrocknet
sind und dann in öl eingelegt wurden die
sind dann auch schon weil es gibt
automaten die sind wirklich ganz trocken
aber diese noch ganz festung hat die
sollte man vorher auf jeden fall mit
heißem wasser übergießen damit die auf
weich werden und das ist sozusagen für
murat immer wie so ein bisschen fleisch
ersatz weil er seine leichte fleisch
konsistenz und die schmecken hat echt
total wird sich und lecker und das passt
hier echt perfekt dazu
[Musik]
denn hier einfach immer mal schön
umrühren ich gebe jetzt da auch noch die
pinienkerne dazu die lasse ich hier am
boden noch ein bisserl anbraten geht
beides parallel
[Musik]
die könnt ihr hier einfach so ein
bisschen rösten bis sie etwas farbe
bekommt haben dann schmecken sie nämlich
viel viel besser
[Musik]
ich gebe ja dann auch schon die
getrockneten tomaten dazu dem auch noch
so ein bisschen öl dabei das kann man
einmal perfekt nehmen zum mit braten
weil es auch bergwerk geschmack von ist
also das öl wirklich nie wegschmeißen
das könnte auch bei dressings benutzen
oder mal so für nudeln zum beispiel
schmeckt echt gut jetzt wird es einfach
schön weiter bis der komplette spinat
hier gelandet ist und einfach schön
verkocht ist das dauert jetzt ein paar
minuten
[Musik]
das sieht ganz gut dass da ich noch sehr
viel flüssigkeit im topf ist und die
lasse ich jetzt noch verkochen damit das
einfach später nicht so durch wässert
das heißt hier aber noch ein paar
minuten schön anbraten und dann wird das
gewürzt mit salz pfeffer muskatnuss will
kann man mit rein machen und dann
schmeckt es auch richtig gut beim salz
ein bisschen aufpassen ich mache noch
keine väter käserei und stellte auch
wird sich also da ziemlich übersetzen
sondern auch samstags
[Musik]
verein immer schön frisch gemahlen ich
muss sagen ich mag nur schwarzem pfeffer
keinen anderen käufer kann ich so gar
nicht riechen das gericht für mich wieso
wie so ein nasser hund und andere
pfeffer sorten möglich auch dass ich bin
so richtig schwarz
grün ab immer kann man
muss
ein bisschen was zu erreichen
den dazugeben
und die körperscanner nicht vergessen
[Musik]
natürlich direkt um jetzt gut abkühlen
kann
rechtzeitig darauf aber nichts
übrigbleiben
muss sie alles aus gekratzt werden bis
zum schluss
keine lebensmittel verschwenden bitte
waschen
da fehlt jetzt eigentlich nur noch der
väter aber dem gebe ich gleich dazu wenn
es ein bisschen abgekühlt ist deswegen
mache ich das hier so ein bisschen nicht
öffnet ist das einfach alles schön
verdampfen kann und kann jetzt schon mal
den hefeteig ausrollen
denn jetzt geht es direkt los mit der
pasta
jetzt nehmt ihr euch entweder eine große
form oder zwei kleine zum beispiel indem
jetzt zwei kleine weil ich sie dann
besser portionen kann und vor allem kann
ich zum beispiel heute eine pastete
anrichten und morgen die andere dann
habe ich einfach nichts an geschnitten
sondern kann schon funktionieren oder
verschenkt jetzt nehmt euch einfach den
teig ich halte ihr denn jetzt auch damit
ich eben beide formen dann gleich
auslegen kann
die sprache ist quasi
eine tagschicht für unten und dann der
tagschicht für oben also nicht mit dem
teig ist alles gut haushalten den teig
vierteln falls ihr zwei förmchen macht
ansonsten wenn ihr eine große habt dann
einfach den teig halbieren
[Musik]
und dann erstmals im oktober jeweils
formen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ok
und dann könnt ihr jetzt den teig
jeweils dünn ausrollen und die form
entweder mit butter ausstreichen mit
olivenöl oder einfach mit bud greenspan
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich nehme jetzt mein opa war dazu das
ist so ein dünner holz aus frau starb
aus der schon so aus der türkischen
traditionellen küche und damit kann man
den teig dünn ausrollen wenn man ihn
hier so drum wickelt natürlich immer
darauf achten dass keine mail dazwischen
es sonst clips und dann mit den fingern
von innen nach außen streichen und dann
öffnet sich der teig
[Musik]
dann hatte ich nämlich die teigplatten
eigentlich eine sockelrente
also
einmal besprühen
und dann den teig da rein legen
dass er schön am rand übersteht
[Musik]
dann habe ich das schon mal dann für die
tankdeckel rolle ich das jetzt auch aus
da brauche ich nicht so viel aber ich
wollte trotzdem groß genug aus denn da
werde ich höchstwahrscheinlich dann
ausstechen darüber legen und den rest
nehme ich dann auch für die dekoration
ja so mache ich das normalerweise müsste
eine pastete nicht der koreaner war ich
finde es auch ist immer mit weil sie
können das auch richtig schön
gestalteten legten von muster ich weiß
noch in irgendeinem film in irgend einem
zeichentrickfilm von damals gab es immer
pasteten habe ich weiß nicht wo das war
war das bei den glücksbärchis oder bei
den
gummibären irgendwo gab es pastete und
die pastete sei immer die war im
internet versorgt gewölbt und dann hatte
sie so kleine
schnitte und es war immer so die pastete
was ist das für ein
ich habe es mir gesehen
wisst ihr was am 1
mit der game of thrones sie täten
muss ich game of thrones anschauen
stütze brutal für mich
ich ertrage zu viele
wenns ne pn es gibt auch nicht okay
es kommt es schon mal zur seite dann
nehme ich mir jetzt
hier die passenden förmchen finde ich
richtig süß
und meine füllung da kommt es natürlich
noch der käserei und wie gesagt nimm die
daten später so wie ich und schafskäse
oder ihr könnt auch ganz gerne einen
hirten käse nehmen aus kuhmilch das geht
auch jetzt könnte denn hier so zu
bröseln
[Musik]
dann die fertige füllung schön in die
pastete reihen füllen
[Musik]
im zimmer land heller da ist ungefähr so
groß wie die pastete und dann kann ich
hier den teig nämlich mal rund
ausschneiden nicht mit einem scharfen
gegenstand auf der silicon matte
schneiden sondern zum beispiel mit
marzipan messer des national so eine
stumpfe schärfe weil es aus kunststoff
besteht
warum schneiden
und den rest nehme ich jetzt gleich für
die dekoration
es steht nur 1 tag habe ich jetzt
erstmal den tag und dann habe ich da
einfach schon mal einen sauberen
abschluss
streiche ich hier den rand mit ein und
zwar hab ich jetzt hier das eiweiß haus
noch wirklich wahr plus ein ganzes
[Musik]
kommt die schöne ausgeschnittener teig
decke drauf
haben übrigens auch schon den ofen
vorbereitet auf 180 grad ober unterhitze
und den restlichen teig verarbeitet
jetzt so ich hatte er denn jetzt hier
erstmal also habe ich einst für die eine
pastete und von anderen tag für die
andere und dann zwiebel ich einfach so
zwei tage strenge umeinander und legt
sie an den rand
[Musik]
dann bestreitet jetzt erstmal noch die
oberfläche mit ein
dann kriegt das ganze auch noch schöne
farbe
wichtig ist bei pastetten auch dass wir
gleich luftlöcher mit rein machen das
heißt entweder nimmt ihr gleich ein
apfel und kerner und könnte noch ein
stechen oder ihr schneidet nur messer
ein denn das ganze hat ja zum einen noch
viel flüssigkeit und feuchtigkeit im
innen- und wenn es dann packt dann
steigt der bahn fuhren wer dann nicht
entweichen kann dann dann explodiert ist
richtig aber es kann ja sein dass es an
der oberfläche reis und deswegen machen
wir direkt gezielten paar öffnungen rein
damit eben der dankeschön entwickeln und
ich mache das sowohl damit es auch schön
auflegt bestreite ich jetzt diese teig
strenge noch mit
dann kann ich es auch besser umeinander
zwirbeln und dann halten sie nämlich
direkt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ihr könnt auch folgendes tun wenn ihr
keinen kranz hier machen wollt könnt ihr
auch zum beispiel ausstecher verwenden
und sogar buchstaben ausstechen und wenn
ihr das ganze zum ramadan zubereiter zum
fastenbrechen abends könnte auch noch
eine schöne botschaft raus beschreiben
was zum öfters zum beispiel ja ist auch
schön dekorativ
ich mache das mit wenig platz
[Musik]
und dann schneide ich jetzt einfach so
ein paar schlitze rein und dann sind es
gibt das mache ich mit so einem bock
schneidemesser
mit einem teig messen könnte aber auch
einfach ein scharfes messer verwenden
und dann ist die pastete bereit für den
backofen
[Musik]
ich kann mich mal
auf cd nummer eins ist fertig und sieht
wundervoll aus und was ich hier richtig
schön finde ich habe ein bisschen
abkühlen aber es ist auf der unterseite
schon ein bisschen bisschen bammel es
die last sehr gut aus der vornehmen zum
anschneiden wenn es nicht klappt können
das aber auch in der form anschneiden
das weist nur zufall dass ich das im
desktop und die habe ich schon länger
gemischten salat dazu und zwar einfach
nur
salatblätter ein bisschen tomaten mais
zwiebel schneide ich da jetzt noch rein
macht es einfach kurz mit der hobel und
dann wird der salat auf die chance auf
türkische art und weise das sind
angemacht mit zitrone salz olivenöl und
sumax mag ist von essig baum gehört das
projekt
zitronensaft und davon wirklich
reichlich
und die zitrone kommt immer mit der
schnittfläche nach unten in die zitrus
presse da hat neulich die nicolet
nämlich tausende nachrichten gekriegt
denn der die zitrone andersrum
reingelegt und jeder jeder historic
sehen hat hat er dann geschrieben
arbeitskreis ich uns hat trotzdem
geklappt hat sie gesagt selbst kümmert
euch um eure eigenen zitronen
ordentlich zitrone ordentlich sein und
zu max so sieht es essig warum gesetz
aus das kommt jetzt auch ordentlich mit
dazu
unschön verrühren
[Musik]
da kommt jetzt nur noch salz rein und
dann ist fertig und heute stelle ich
euch noch hier und
[Applaus]
salz sie hat ja so winken die aus den
videos noch nicht nur aus tories genau
ich weiß noch auf keinem
schnellinfos coburg die asseln hat
nämlich bei uns ganz lange im shop in
mannheim gearbeitet und eigentlich von
anfang an und jetzt ist er hier noch in
waghäusel und mannheim bin ich auch noch
ein bisschen weil da steckt ja doch noch
sein herzblut drin der ja voll das ist
immer so für die verständigung der stadt
die filialleiterin und wer hat es damals
kennengelernt als das war auch bei der
pressemitteilung heißt mitteilung hatten
für einen shop in mannheim und da hatten
wir noch niemanden für den shop also wir
mal sagen wir noch im shop und dann
gucken wir halt jetzt mal wie würde es
machen und dann kam die jahresmitte
fragt ob wir noch verkäufer bräuchten
und dann habe ich zwei erfolgen und dann
hat sie so kurz mitsprache und dann habe
ich es geht mir einfach deine bewerbung
oder wenig zum baden zeigt dass ich
sagen die nehmen wir mal als
filialleitung das ist bis heute das ist
das versteht ja das ist als er drauf hat
dankeschön und sie passt sie perfekt so
fand sie einfach so von herz nimmt ja
mein stories kennt das schon und jetzt
gerät die passiert öfter aber jetzt
schon das zweite auge das zweite
feuer
was hast du gemacht hast
da hat mich auf die idee gebracht die
post ihre mutter ich würd mal einen ofen
rezept machen und dann kommen sie um die
ecke sagt machte eine pastete und da
habe ich gedacht das passt weil
irgendwie so bisselik ja das sind wir
außerdem geld ja jetzt habe ich das mal
hier auf skepsis ja und ich finde das
sieht echt gut aus was man kann das ja
auch mit
blätterteig machen aber ich finde es vor
mit hefeteig schon
schön bischofs käse spinat da bin ich
mal gespannt
lecker sind holländer aus das habe ich
natürlich kein thema
kurz im keller
[Gelächter]
weinkeller vox übernehme ich habe nichts
gefunden entstand aus dem keller hat ich
muss noch mal kurz runter
christoph amrein im keller
naja einmal pastete getrocknete tomaten
habe ich noch drin
den gleichen schmeckt gut da bin ich mir
sicher dass
mit koch schon packt auch richtig gern
und auch sehr komisch
ihre mama auch in der
verteilung innerhalb gerne das essen
war folgerichtig
länder probiert ich kann nicht gerne
sagen
und die pinienkerne die da drin das ist
auch gibt dem irgendwie so ein quatsch
ich guck mir empfehlen können doch als
ich finde schon ein tolles rezept wird
es dann mal mache ich
hab's auch beim opfer wagen macht ja da
wird doch noch ein blogger spinne hat
uns
ja
okay
vielleicht doch
jedenfalls lassen wir es uns jetzt
schmecken ich wünsche mir auch einen
guten appetit probiert das rezept gerne
mal aus wie gesagt können das auch noch
am nächsten tag essen gerne auch noch
mal aufwärmen uns lässt sich super
vorbereiten ich finde es auch ein recht
schnelles rezept muss man sagen und mit
dem salat passt auch ideal muss echt
sagen haben also was frisch ist und dass
und mir reicht so was auch zum
abendessen das als ich weiß meine mama
die macht halt immer so vorspeisen und
suppe gut zu bewerben hat den marken
immer auch das finde ich immer gut das
hat dann finde ich reicht mir sowas
eigentlich als hauptgericht deswegen
probiert's gerne auch guten arbeitet
euch einen schönen ramadan wünschen wir
euch
genau wird aber sagen nach auf meinem
kanal findet ihr ganz viele rezeptideen
dazu wir werden ganz viele stories
hochladen dass er jeden tag eben auch
rezept inspirationen habt und könnte
auch die rezepte gerne teilen und
übersetzen und portionen umrechnen in
der app genau das können wir gerne
machen also bis zum nächsten mal schießt
jetzt heim morgen unser mittagessen
endlich
[Musik]